hello guys I'm Ryan right hi guys I'm
Veronica six times there's this video
that we're gonna discuss today that let
me see who it's from Ivy should have
bookmarked it what's it gonna be it's
called Darth Zannah from corridor
digital don't know what this video is
but it sounds like a be worth talking
about let's find out what it is you
ready baby nuggets
[ __ ]
mr. Sirko
Jedi
yeah
we consider subscribing these are the
videos I've never seen corridor digital
videos it's relevant that's for sure
it's relevant I mean a good idea to do a
sketch about Darth Vader around the time
of the Christmas release of Star Wars
perfect perfect idea secondly I like the
skit in general the car I like a sketch
where the concept alone is funny you
know like sometimes you see sketches
that especially like nowadays on
Saturday live where the concept of the
sketch is not that funny and you're
waiting for it to unfold to be funny I
like it where it's like immediate the
concept of Darth Vader being Santa Claus
it is a pretty funny concept I like how
he starts bonding with the stormtrooper
and stuff and having a great time it's
like if Darth Vader was celebrating
Christmas this is probably how good he'd
be a little punk now was that little kid
his son yeah I mean I think I guess
that's where does imply my says dad you
know making fun of the whole you are my
father thing and then he obliterated him
used the force on him which if you say
the sentence like in a script Darth
Vader uses the force on a kid that
sounds disgusting
that sounds pedophilia like yeah it
sounds pedophilia like whirring you guys
Darth Vader maybe a pedophile there's
this scene in Return of the Jedi that we
were watching one of the like the second
scene where the Emperor and Darth Vader
are having a long exchange of dialogue
about about Luke Skywalker everything
they say sounds like they're talking
about molesting Luke
oh yeah after you're done with the boy
you bring him to me how do you know he's
here I felt him
Darth Vader boys I felt it you know
little tidbit I really did like when he
what did when he flies away with the TIE
fighters as the reindeer yeah that was a
cool little bit I enjoy that a lot
anyway guys listen if you're new to the
channel I want you to that's my line wow
you really loudly yeah well you were
talking over me I'm your boyfriend I
wasn't called for you show me respect at
all times if you're gonna cry can you
not do that on camera there's a
perfectly comfortable bed over there
just say what you were gonna say
subscribe to the real rejects it's a
positive thing to do
I'm putting the subscribe button over
there you could check out Veronica's
channel hey there's a lot of vlogs and
acoustic covers there were some vlogs
that she did in December in New York
check it out
mean mr. Kady he wants the Metal Gear
Solid poster I have and he wants a
shout-out mean mr. Kady let's see what
you look like oh my god it's the son of
Satan everyone look at this guy that is
the devil right here you are me no he's
just scruffy and artistic look at his
hair and his it's the way he carries
himself yeah he looks Mexican black
which is not Satan so I take that back
movies mixed yeah the devil is not
Mexican or black I just want to say that
I want to make that clear I'm gonna say
what race he really is
damn Filipinos maybe Porto Rican
Porterie Puerto Rican yeah I could see
the Puerto Rican he's not any of those
he's he's he's a son of Satan